[Music]  power and the transformation  of beauty is really quite something  isn't it  and chris really did pin this in good  it's funny you know you see those people  who like it's so seamless you're like  how do they have short hair one day and  like a long hair the next oh that's how  as long as i've been in this business  even i am still like i don't see the  seams  what is going on  i could run a marathon  this way who am i fooling i'm not  running any marathons i it's a shock if  i can get out of this chair i can't get  out of the hair oh my god  i can't get out of this  oh my god i mean it  i'm stuck ah  okay so apparently you need a  professional to get into this look and  out of it i need a locksmith i've taken  wigs off my whole  oh life god now i'm actually having a  panic attack  oh i see there's a nice braid back there  oh  oh that's a lock  oh my god  [Music]  that's a wrap  you